we have a new best designed folding flip
phone on the planet in my opinion which
is this this is the Oppo Find N2 flip so
these all kind of look like the Samsung
Galaxy Z flip if you zoom out enough but
this is better than that and every other
folding flip phone I've seen for three
key reasons first is actually the crease
this crease in the middle appears to be
the smoothest yet not the highest bar
since you can still kind of see all of
them but for a phone that folds in half
and gives you a big 6.8 inch display
this is good then two is just the design
across the board like I said they look
similar but I like these flat sides it's
got a matte finish and folded up it is
quite thin and gapless but number one is
definitely this cover screen this cover
display here is the biggest we've seen
it's 3.26 inches which puts it basically
at the same size and shape as the Palm
phone but it also has the right aspect
ratio to be functional so not only on
your notifications readable but there
are widgets here and extra functionality
there's quick settings and of course if
you want to take a selfie you can open
the camera and use a much better quality
main cameras instead of the selfie
camera